[MUSIC PLAYING]
APARNA SINHA: Hello, everyone.
I'm Aparna Sinha, Director
of Product Management
at Google Cloud.
Welcome to our Cloud keynote.
I'm here along with Matthew
Izatt from Google Workspace.
Thank you for taking time
out of your busy week
to join us at this exciting
time for developers
with Google Cloud.
Today's keynote will
focus on the Built
to Help theme that you've been
hearing throughout I/O. Built
to Help is a guiding
principle at Google,
and it runs through
all our work,
connecting our consumer
and Cloud products.
At Google, we're passionate
about developers,
and we are humbled and inspired
by the amazing innovations
that you've introduced
using Google products.
You've told us that you
appreciate the simplicity
of Google Cloud Services.
That is not a given on other
clouds, where the complexity
can be overwhelming.
Making technology
easier for developers
doesn't happen by chance.
Google is deeply
invested in ensuring
a developer-centric cloud,
where everyone can innovate.
You've told us loud and clear
that you want more time to code
and less toil.
So today, we will demo
several new services
from Google Cloud and Google
Workspace that are powerful,
yet simple to use.
How does Google Cloud make the
developer experience easier?
Well, first, our services
integrate nicely,
giving you a full stack
that's specifically
tailored to backend, web,
mobile, and data analytics
applications.
The stack aligns Google Cloud's
Compute, Storage, Database,
and AI and ML services to the
needs of your application.
Second, critical
technology expertise
from years of Google
research is directly
built into these stacks.
As a result, you don't have
to be a full-stack developer.
You can build like one.
The value of an
end-to-end stack is
that it helps you get
started quickly on day one,
and that means faster
time to market.
But down the road, it also
means that we proactively
solve your day-two and
day-three challenges, challenges
like scalability, observability,
and software supply chain
security.
Now, the biggest
day-one challenge
is often iterating until
you find product market
fit for your service.
Take an example.
Let's say we're trying to get a
new mobile app off the ground.
Our demo app,
Community Assist, is
going to connect people
to volunteer opportunities
in their community.
Firebase is going to be a
really good option for us
because of its excellent
A/B testing capabilities
and also because it helps
us set up our OAuth flow.
Over 3 million developers
from startups to enterprises
have been using Firebase to
engage billions of users.
In this demo,
we're going to show
you additional
benefits of this stack,
like the downstream integration
with Cloud Functions, Cloud
Firestore, BigQuery, Cloud
Run, and other services.
Now, to reach our
addressable market,
our app needs to be accessible
by everyone in our community.
And that means we need
to support languages
from around the world.
The Google Cloud Translate
API is perfect for this.
Cloud Functions for
Firebase can, in fact,
be used to trigger
the Translate app API.
Here's a simple function
that we've written.
Let's test it and try
translating the phrase
from English to my
favorite language, Hindi.
Here is the output in Hindi.
[SPEAKING HINDI] And with
a few more lines of code,
we can support not just Hindi
but over a hundred world
languages.
Now, to really test
product market fit,
we're going to add an in-app
feedback form to the community
app, and that's going to help
us see what's resonating with
our users and what isn't.
A common challenge
here is making
sense of the unstructured,
free-text feedback data
that we're going to
hear from our users.
This, again, is where Google
Cloud's integrated stack
comes in.
As you can see, this
stack integrates
Firebase with BigQuery,
Vertex AI, and other services
through Cloud Firestore.
So what you get here is
Database, Compute, Analytics,
and AI and ML services
integrated together
for a faster application
development experience.
Cloud Firestore is
an excellent option
for mobile and web development.
It's a NoSQL database
with built-in integrations
to Firebase and Flutter
and to Google Cloud.
And because it's
serverless, we never
have to worry about
maintaining it or scaling it.
In our app, the incoming
customer feedback
is free-text data, and we're
storing it in Firestore.
So let's check this out in
Firestore for the comments.
Here, we see that our users
are saying, "How can I
find organizations near me?"
Or "This app is amazing."
Well, it looks like some of
our users are liking the app.
Firestore has a really great
integration with BigQuery.
It easily exports
the data to BigQuery.
BigQuery is an industry-leading,
fully managed, serverless cloud
data warehouse that can scale
to hundreds of petabytes.
BigQuery customers
analyze over 110 terabytes
of data per second, so we're
in very good hands here.
Let's check out how this works.
We've installed the Firestore
to BigQuery extension.
Here, you can see the
customer feedback.
"Love the new features," as
well as "How do I upgrade
my app to unlock donations?"
This is all in Cloud Store.
These same comments
can also now be
seen in BigQuery, thanks to the
extension we just installed.
Super straightforward,
easy, yet very powerful,
because with our
data and BigQuery,
we can uncover deep insights
quickly using Vertex AI.
We're going to use
Vertex AI to categorize
each of our user inputs into
one of three categories.
It's either a bug
report, or it's feedback,
or it's a pricing issue.
Vertex AI is Google Cloud's
unified artificial intelligence
platform.
It provides building blocks
for various machine learning
applications, like Vision,
Video, and many more.
Vertex AI offers core
services for data science,
machine learning, and ML ops
in a single unified platform.
You can also go deeper into
custom model development.
Overall, in comparison
to other platforms,
training a model with Vertex
AI requires 80% less code.
And most importantly,
you don't need
to be an ML expert or a
PhD to leverage Vertex AI.
Let's see this in action
and classify our user input
into those three categories.
We've trained a model to detect
different types of feedback.
Check out our model
here in the Models tab.
We click on the model
name, and it takes us
to the confusion matrix.
That's shown in blue.
This matrix shows us how
often the model has classified
each label correctly.
Over here, we have
the Test and Deploy
tab that allows us to deploy
our model to a REST endpoint.
From there, we can easily call
it from a web or mobile app.
Plus, it lets us make
sample predictions
right here from within the UI.
Let's try a sample now.
Here's a text--
"the loading times
are so slow now on my Pixel 4."
In fact, the model
correctly identified
that this is a bug report.
Shall we try another one?
This text says, "thank
you for this release
the new features are great."
And we can see that the model
predicted this to be feedback
and does that with
pretty high confidence.
Now, let's say we want to use
this model from a mobile or web
app.
Right here in Vertex AI,
we can see the Python code
that we would need.
This code can be used to
call this cloud-hosted model
from our app.
There's also client libraries
in other languages available.
But we actually want
to use this model
to make predictions on our text
data that's stored in BigQuery.
So how can we call Python
functions on BigQuery data?
Well, to do that, we will use
BigQuery remote functions.
This is a brand-new
capability in BigQuery.
Here, you see our customer
input data in BigQuery
without any categories.
Let's add a
classification column
to show the categories
assigned by Vertex AI.
We're going to use a Cloud
Function to call the Vertex
model we just built to
classify each piece of input
as a bug report, feedback, or
pricing issue within BigQuery.
You can use any language
that Cloud Function supports,
but today, as you can
see, we're using Python.
Next, we'll call this function
using SQL within BigQuery.
Let's run the query.
And here, you can see the
user input data is categorized
right back here in BigQuery.
BigQuery remote functions
are not only easy to use
but also very
powerful because they
combine BigQuery with any
Google Cloud product or API.
That was a great
example of automation,
but there's much more you can
do with Google Cloud Services.
Let's take this further and
automate the appropriate action
for each category
of our user input.
We want bug reports filed
on GitHub as issues.
Guess what?
That's easy.
We can use Cloud Run and its
newly launched serverless
jobs capability that
lets us run batch
jobs on demand, on a schedule,
or via an event trigger.
We've built a Cloud Run job
to extract the bug reports
from our data and create
GitHub issues for our team
to triage and fix.
I can schedule my job to
execute whenever I want it to.
I've been running it nightly,
but let's trigger the job
manually to see it run now.
While it's running,
I'll mention that this
isn't the only job we have.
We love Cloud Run jobs.
So we also have jobs to
move customer service issues
to the customer service
ticket tracker and a job
to create an email summary
of each day's feedback
for our executives.
And now our job has
finished executing.
And you can see that there's
a new issue tagged Mobile Bug
Report in GitHub,
just as it should be.
This has the comments that a
user put into our mobile app
earlier.
Cloud Run jobs can run
multiple tasks in parallel.
So we can scale
our app as we grow.
I encourage you to try out
Firestore, Cloud Functions,
Cloud Run jobs,
BigQuery, and Vertex AI
to accelerate the time to market
of your latest innovations.
Once you've found product market
fit, a new set of challenges
will await you as your app
grows to millions of users.
These day-two or day-three
challenges include scalability,
observability, and software
supply chain security.
Fortunately, we have used
serverless technology
throughout our app so far.
BigQuery, Cloud
Functions, and Cloud Run
are fully managed
serverless capabilities.
So as we get more
users, they're going
to scale up automatically.
But let's look at a more
difficult scalability
challenge.
As our app grew, so did the
volunteers and opportunities,
and we decided to add a map view
to our app to show volunteers
what opportunities are nearby.
Google Maps platform
is a popular API
amongst developers because
of its scale, coverage,
and familiarity.
We stored our volunteer and
opportunity location data
in a Postgres database because
Postgres has great location
data support out of the box.
But as it turned
out, our growth was
much faster than the Postgres
database could handle.
These red pins here on
the map show how strong
the interest has been.
Now our app has
started slowing down,
and we're getting complaints
about volunteer numbers
not showing up right, as well
as people signing up for already
filled opportunities.
What are we going to do?
Well, we could
optimize our database,
but that would require having
the right expertise in house
or the time to hire for it.
We could shrink the scope of
volunteers and opportunities
to reduce the load
on our database,
but that's not
really a good option
because it would limit
the growth of our app.
Thankfully, we don't
need to do either.
AlloyDB is a new and
powerful relational database
from Google Cloud that's fully
compatible with PostgreSQL.
With AlloyDB, we can easily
build apps and scale them
to millions of users, all while
using existing open source
Postgres skills.
And because AlloyDB is
fully Postgres compatible,
we can switch our Postgres
instance to AlloyDB
without making any
changes to our application
code or our queries.
Most importantly here, the
accelerated performance
of AlloyDB means that we can
continue querying our volunteer
data in real time without
slowing down the app.
Success.
Our next day-two challenge
is observability,
which involves
troubleshooting and isolating
root causes of potential
service disruptions.
Google Cloud has
us covered here.
First, our compute options,
BigQuery and Firebase,
have in-context
observability data
right within the Cloud Console.
This one unified view across
logs, events, metrics,
and service-level objectives
requires zero setup
to help quickly
connect the dots and
root-cause day-two problems.
In addition to this,
day-two ops also
requires cohesive monitoring,
visualization, and diagnostics
at the network level.
That's why today, I'm
thrilled to announce
the launch of Network
Analyzer, a new tool that's
part of the Network Intelligence
Center in Google Cloud.
Network Analyzer proactively
analyzes configurations,
firewall rules, routes, IP
addresses, and network capacity
utilization to detect
potential problems
and make recommendations
that help you minimize
mean time to resolution.
Last but not least,
we developers
increasingly need to plan for
potential security attacks.
All of these can
happen at any time.
They are particularly damaging
to an at-scale production
system.
Recent software
supply chain attacks,
like SolarWinds,
Mimecast, and Codecov,
show the importance of securing
each link in our supply chain,
right from source
through to deploy.
Software supply chain
security is natively
built into Google Cloud's
developer tool chain.
This can be a great
benefit for developers,
especially if you're in
a regulated industry,
such as fintech or retail.
Cloud Build, our
service for building,
testing, and deploying code to
VMs, serverless, Kubernetes,
or Firebase, now offers SLSA
level 2 compliance by default.
SLSA is an emerging standard
that encapsulates industry
best practices for software
supply chain integrity.
Cloud Build implements
these practices by default,
so you and I don't have
to be security experts.
Cloud Build also provides
verifiable build provenance.
This provenance helps you trace
a binary to its source code
to prevent tampering
and to prove
that the code you're
running is the code that you
think you're running.
You can see here an attestation.
This is metadata
about the build.
It's labeled
built-by-cloud-build.
This metadata indicates
that the build
is legitimate
because it's signed
by Cloud Build, the service.
Cloud Build is the first service
to offer a zero-configuration,
out-of-the-box experience
for build provenance.
Stitching together
this type of experience
is not straightforward
in competing products.
Google Cloud also offers Binary
Authorization integration,
which ensures that only
builds verified by Cloud Build
are deployed to production.
Here, you can see us
trying to deploy an image.
This image is not verified
or signed by Cloud Build.
And so, with Binary
Authorization,
this deployment step fails.
And when we try
deploying an image that
is signed by Cloud Build, it
goes through to deployment.
In summary, what we've shown you
today showcases our integrated
end-to-end stack and how it can
help you get started quickly
to achieve accelerated
time to market on day one
and also to proactively solve
your pressing day-two and
day-three issues, like
scalability, observability,
and software supply
chain security.
Before I go, I want to talk
about one more innovation that
is hot off the presses.
It allows you to easily
develop interactive experiences
for your customers
and prospects.
We're excited to announce
Immersive Stream for XR.
This service renders
extended reality experiences
using Google Cloud's
GPUs, and it streams them
to millions of mobile
devices around the world.
By using Immersive
Stream for XR,
you can engage your users in
an immersive, interactive,
photorealistic experience
without them ever
having to download an app.
And best of all, you'll save
time on development and testing
because you can simply
create content once,
knowing that it will run
on any mobile device,
regardless of model,
year, or operating system.
Immersive Stream for XR
powers our interactive flyover
experience for Maps that Sundar
announced during his keynote.
And it's also powering a
next-generation car-buying
experience from Ford,
as well as my favorite,
an augmented reality
kitchen visualizer
by Lowe's, and a virtual
shopping assistant by KDDI.
To get started, visit this URL
including interactive demos
from our partners.
We can't wait to
see what you create
with this technology
and the end-to-end stack
from Google Cloud.
With that, I'd like to
welcome Matthew Izatt to share
all about the innovation coming
to you from Google Workspace.
[WHOOSH]
MATTHEW IZATT: Thanks, Aparna.
It's great to see all
the incredible innovation
for developers coming
from Google Cloud.
Hi, everyone.
I'm Matthew Izatt, Product
Lead for the Google Workspace
platform, and I'm here to show
you the latest opportunities
for developers to enhance
your development productivity
and deliver powerful joint
solutions with Google
Workspace.
Google Workspace is firstly
a product and platform
that gives software
developers all the tools they
need to work
efficiently together,
collaborate on a
design document,
chat about a
production incident,
or meet live and be
productive from anywhere.
But not only is Workspace
a product for developers
to innovate with.
It's a platform to build on.
You can integrate
with, customize,
and extend Workspace.
Combining Workspace with
your ingenuity, your talent,
and your products
means, together, we'll
offer even greater
productivity solutions.
1 plus 1 truly becomes 3 when
we build better together.
Google Workspace is a
platform for developers.
I mentioned integrating
with, customizing,
and extending Workspace.
Integrate with
Workspace through dozens
of enterprise-quality
APIs, covering everything
from Workspace apps, like Gmail
and Drive, to admin controls,
to solutions for
managing identity.
Customize through automating
your previously tedious manual
and multi-step processes.
Extend Workspace by building
seamless user experiences
directly into the Workspace UI.
It's also a platform for
creating software and can
improve the software
development experience.
Developers can connect
their DevOps tools
to Workspace to improve
their efficiency
and accelerate software
development, for example,
manage and discuss your
Jira tickets in Google Chat.
And finally, Workspace is
also a platform and a team
that developers
can partner with,
going to market
with global reach,
so you can be where your
present and future users are.
Let's take a look at
some of the opportunities
to integrate with or
develop on Workspace.
We'll start with Google
Workspace add-ons,
available across
Workspace to connect apps
that work better together.
Add-ons enable you to
develop tight integrations
into the Google
experience, living side
by side with where
knowledge workers are
spending most of their days.
Add-ons are built on
an open framework that
lets you use your preferred
language, development stack,
and preferred cloud provider.
Of course, we think you'll
have the smoothest and most
powerful experience building
your add-ons in Google Cloud.
The add-on framework
is very flexible.
Build once and make the
add-on available across both
desktop and mobile and
in one or many Workspace
apps, such as Gmail,
Calendar, Drive and Docs.
Google Chat is not only an
effective communications tool.
It's also a powerful ally
to optimize workflows.
Integrate with Google Chat to
create a user experience that's
interactive, inline, and
intelligent with the power
of Google AI.
We are continuously
improving the Chat platform
to make it more powerful
and easier to develop for.
We're excited about
recent developments
to help you build
better Chat apps.
Interactive cards
and dialogues allow
users to interact with your app
through a graphical interface.
No need to remember obscure
commands or guess at keywords.
Reassign that Asana
task with just a click.
For power users and
hyperefficiency,
nothing beats slash commands.
Slash commands make
addressing Chat apps faster
and help users get the
most out of your app.
Link previews help
keep information
in line and in context
within the conversation,
while eliminating the need
to interrupt your focus
by context switching
between multiple apps
to find key information.
And finally, we've
worked on offering
a wider selection of design
options for the card interface.
These improvements are
a set of visual updates
and new widget offerings
for a better experience.
Put it all together,
and what you
see is that we're really
helping our demonstration users,
Ann and Shirley,
move efficiently
through the design phase
of the desk booking app
they are working on.
For when you need more direct
control of resources in Chat,
we are happy to announce
new updates to the Chat API.
With our expansion
of the Chat API,
we will offer the ability
to create, read, update,
and delete all the key
resources in Google Chat,
from individual
messages to spaces.
So, for example,
developers will now
be able to use the Chat
API to create new spaces
and add the right members to
the space programmatically.
We added these new
features to help
you build more powerful
applications on top of Chat,
and it's immediately
obvious how helpful
these can be for developers.
For example, an
incident response app,
such as PagerDuty, will now be
able to automatically create
a space with the relevant
incident commanders
when an outage
has been detected.
On the roadmap, we are also
planning to roll out more APIs.
Let me describe a
couple of examples.
First, APIs for
create group chats
and create direct
messages offer you
more ways to programmatically
initiate conversations
and actions across teams.
Additionally, when you want to
provide assistance in a space
without users having
to initiate a request,
we will permit apps to listen
to all messages in a space,
so an app can proactively
jump in to help as needed.
To get more details on
the updates for Chat,
join my colleague
Ramesh in an I/O session
covering what's new in the
world of Google Chat apps.
Google, at its heart, is a
company built by developers.
And as a developer, we recognize
that IDEs and repositories
aren't the only tools you
need to build software.
You also need to connect
your development tool change
to your communications
tools, like Google Chat,
to keep the engineering
team connected as part
of the development lifecycle.
Whether a build failed, a
prod push got interrupted,
or your team has finally
finished that last sprint
towards building their
desk booking app,
you'll want to use some of
these leading DevOps tools
to help you get your work done.
And we have more in the
pipeline, so stay tuned.
Now let's take a quick look
at one of these DevOps tools,
PagerDuty.
We're thrilled to announce the
new PagerDuty app for Chat.
When a production
system is down,
you want automated incident
management and quick team
actions in Chat.
And yes, in the era of hybrid
and flexible office work,
I would definitely consider a
failure of your desk booking
app to be a production incident.
Fortunately, the combination
of Chat and PagerDuty
are here to help your
team respond quickly
and resolve the problem.
Moving on to another area
of the Workspace platform,
we're thrilled to announce new
APIs for live sharing in Google
Meet.
With Meet live
sharing, users can now
share real-time,
interactive experiences
with each other via
Google Meet, so everyone
can feel part of the action.
From a developer perspective,
there are two key new aspects.
First, Meet's new State Sync
API will sync your app's content
across all participant
devices with shared controls.
Second, cross-platform
multi-screen support
allows you to
programmatically launch
a picture-in-picture
version of Meet
to simultaneously show the
meeting in the same view
as your content.
And yes, I said cross-platform.
Anywhere you can run Meet, which
is pretty much anywhere-- web,
Android, iOS, even Chromecast--
you can integrate and
experience live sharing.
I'm sure you'd love
to get more details,
and we have a lot more to share.
Learn how to enable shared
experiences across platforms
in a session presented by PMs
from Google Meet and YouTube.
When you've built an integration
using one of the new features
above or our already great
Gmail, Drive, or Calendar APIs,
you'll then focus
on distribution.
For that, the Google
Workspace Marketplace
is the place where you
can have global visibility
with all Workspace users.
We've seen billions
of app installs
by Workspace users and thousands
of apps published by developers
in the Marketplace.
But what if you're building
a private app meant
for your company only?
Perhaps it's that
custom desk booking app
that we've seen a lot of today.
Fortunately, the
Marketplace is also
designed to be the vehicle for
deployment within a company,
either through
administrator-driven
deployments or through special
sections of the Marketplace,
clearly indicating
internal apps approved
for specific internal users.
We've also made many
recent enhancements
to the Marketplace.
For admins, you can
now deploy Chat apps
via domain-wide installation
from the Marketplace.
As well, admins now have more
granular app access controls
through organizational
units or groups.
For end users,
admins, and anyone
who is exploring
the Marketplace,
we strengthened transparency
and disclosure, improving
app descriptions,
permissions, and reviews.
We've also added the
Approved for you category,
so users have a clear indication
of IT-approved applications.
Finally, for developers
and distributors,
we have enhanced the
Developer Dashboard
and updated the Marketplace
badge to help discovery.
Opportunity abounds with
the Workspace platform--
reach billions of
users and millions
of paying businesses
across the world.
There are not many
platforms today
that provide this scale
of reach for developers.
The breadth of the
Workspace platform offering
enables you to build a
wide range of solutions,
build tight integrations
into all the Workspace
apps for seamless experience,
create intelligent workflows
using Chat, transform business
data accessible via dozens
of APIs into strategic
insights, use a single identity
across many services.
And finally, impact--
customers choose Workspace
because it transforms
their business and drives
productivity and
strategic thinking.
Add your ingenuity and insights,
and the impact we can have
together is unlimited.
Thanks again for joining
our Cloud team today.
Here are a few links to learn
more about today's topics.
We can't wait to see what you
build with Workspace and Google
Cloud.
Thanks, and enjoy
the rest of I/O.
[MUSIC PLAYING]